[MUSIC PLAYING]
LARRY YANG: I'm Larry Yang.
I am with the Play
Commerce team.
We are the team that
helps you collect money
from your players.
And I'm here to
give you three ideas
on how you can make more money
than the person sitting next
to you.
So idea number one--
collect some data
and do an experiment.
Let's say you've just created
a brand new puzzle game
and you've just launched it.
And you're getting a
quarter million store
visits every week, 27% of them
are converting into installs.
That's great, right?
Is it great?
How do you know if
it's great or not?
So with a recently launched
feature in the Play Developer
console, you can now
compare your performance
against your peer group.
So now you see that your 27%
install conversion is actually
in the top quartile
of other puzzle games.
That's great, right?
Now you can break
out your champagne.
But hold on.
What's that little
red bar that's
down there a little bit lower?
You scroll down and you
click in and now you
see whoa, WTF in South Korea.
You're actually
only at around 13%.
That's actually in
the lowest quartile.
What's going on?
So Play Developer
console will also
give you a suggestion to run
a store listings experiment.
Maybe the text in
your app description
isn't appropriate or doesn't
work for the local audience.
Maybe your screenshots
aren't localized,
so people in South
Korea are looking
at screenshots in
English and they're
like, I don't know
what this game does.
And so idea one, collect
some data, run an experiment,
and try to improve
your app performance.
Idea number two, what's better
than a user that pays you once?
A user that pays you
every single month.
So a few developers are
starting to experiment
with the idea of subscribing
to non-consumable items
in their game.
Supercell's "Boom
Beach," in there you can
subscribe to an extra builder.
So now you can
rebuild your buildings
and build up your army and
get back to battle faster
than other people in the game.
Glu Mobile's "Deer
Hunter" has an ability--
they have multiple tiers
of subscriptions where
you can earn gold or
earn points and level up
faster so that you can level
up and get at the higher levels
faster.
In fact, when you look
across play and games,
we've seen a 50% increase in
the number of subscriptions
being offered in games.
So give that a try, think
about how a subscription might
be a way to generate
recurring revenue
as well as improving
your player engagement.
Idea number three
is around refunds.
What's better than refunding
somebody their money?
It's never refunding
that person their money.
So some of you are probably
familiar with refund abuse.
That's where a player
goes into your game,
they buy the bag of gems, and
then they go into the game
and they use the bag
of gems-- or worse,
they sell the bag of
gems on the black market.
Then they go and refund
and get their money back.
So not only is that
bad, because you're not
getting any money
from this person,
but that person
is now destroying
your in-game economy.
So what we've
recently done is we
launched a new API called
voidedPurchases, where now you
know that that player
has gotten a refund.
And so now you can
go into the game,
into that player's profile,
and take back or claw back
that person's item.
Before we had released
this recently,
we'd been doing some testing
with some early access
partners.
And we've seen
that with this API,
they've seen a significant
decrease in refunds.
This shows that a big
chunk of their refunds
were actually due to
this refund abuse.
So give the
voidedPurchases API a try
and claw back and cut
down on your refund abuse.
So to recap, three ideas
to make more money.
Get some data,
run an experiment,
try subscriptions,
offering a subscription
to a nonconsumable item to
generate recurring revenue
and increased engagement.
And thirdly, try the
voidedPurchases API
to cut down on refund abuse.
Thanks and good
luck with your game.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]